what does it actually mean to be part of
uh a world like what does it mean to
both of you to be part of a show that
still resonates with so many people 30
years after it first premiered I mean
and I'm just curious if you talk a
little bit about that 35 years it's a
privilege obviously and a blessing and
I think if anything
this season three of Picard
is as strong as we've ever been as a uh
in terms of the writing in terms of the
acting of the storytelling
and uh because we have not played these
parts in a long time
it was fun to come back to them with the
uh wisdom of some age and uh new
confidence and new experiences and I I
I'm I think it's thrilling and the the
the in as much as our relationships
among each other have deepened you know
we've talked about this the work is that
much more rich and and nuanced
um and Powerful
um so there's there's a lot to be said
for
um the history that we have together and
the time in between right
um and now getting an opportunity I
personally never thought that we would
get this chance to to go out consciously
um this is a real blessing yeah
listen as a fan it was thrilling to see
the people that have not been together
in over 20 years together and I just
want to know what it was like that first
day on set when everyone was together
um and you know what it was like well
it's probably a little different than
you imagine because we get together we
have been friends for 35 years we've
stood up at each other's weddings and
the god parents to each other's kids and
been through divorces and there's
there's a lot of history and we have
dinner and coffee and drinks and we do
conventions together in sex yeah yeah we
have a hysterical group text so it
wasn't
a surprise and we knew who had everybody
looked like and we it was uh with this
we just happened to be go to work
together for first time in a while so it
would there weren't any
it was no there were no shocking uh
reunions yeah
I know what you mean um so I am curious
they're the third season is ten episodes
uh which is the one that you're most
looking forward to fans seeing well I've
seen five and six and that's all six is
awesome six is six six doesn't suck yes
which is awesome
4 is awesome
a 10 is awesome
one and two pretty good yeah that three
is great yeah five yeah excellent five
is really really good eight
so no I think
I think it's pretty good all the way
through I mean that's what I'm getting
yeah yeah
look no I I honestly and I say this as
uh I uh I don't actually think you have
to have watched season one and two of
Picard to watch season three do you
agree with that 100 not only that that
hasn't really been true since first
Contact yep which we all agreed that you
don't have to have seen any Star Trek in
order to enjoy first Contact you can
come to it fresh and new and I I think
that's true for season three of picardo
as well I completely agree with Levar
yeah but that was a script that was
bulletproof headscript yeah I'm pretty
depth at the hell
I gotta say oh I gotta stop I'm just
gonna say seriously I love talking to be
able to talk to you guys and I wish you
nothing but the best today appreciate
you